there's so much in the road for rich
dicks as well but again we'll pass
different planets I'm sure each one of
these players has a plan for themselves
but only one of them is gonna make it
man only one it's been a long day so far
especially in this LCQ but again this is
not even the main event right now we're
gonna go into this matchup
Oh as well versus ivu you thought he
wouldn't show his face true form
you thought humanity didn't need saving
at some point well he's here now let's
see how as well is gonna mix things up
here in this matchup like this what the
Nords anyway let's get it to him a plane
to set it off rod spinner they don't
start and again it stinks with the quick
talk into the instant launch doesn't
want to deal with IRA shenanigans asking
anything be careful three out of five
and you have a lot to deal with it
usually it's rich sticks on the
receiving end of affiliate bus the
muscle Buster's but when you can't beat
them join them right talk to him but hey
I like this kick I mean because it's an
extended set you want to test things out
you want to see how effective this as
well is gonna be and you never know he
might be able to be in cruise control
but that's not the case of this
tournament so far right now they're
going back and forth they're both in the
yellow yeah personal was saying with an
extreme distinct character this date for
this character I feel like that's maybe
a lot of people he said like you know
top tier for whatever like he actually
just hates everything about it on top of
being good so let's see how hablar
hating on good design I'm offended yeah
see we're talking about you don't hit
this believe it decide it's a bit
different for the rest of us either way
he's gonna have to hold that ring out
whether he likes it or not as bridge
sticks carrying on the offense
soul charging his way to safety he's
about to eat another muscle phone
over those weapon art see what he does
here I arrived it out here and still it
acts nice good round here this ain't so
far yeah I mean sold charts efficiency
is very high for that of same here comes
the shot class of back wall full enough
to get the kill even at a wide angle
with a little bit of extra damage always
helps it now we got service nice stuck
again you know he's been able to snip
that out quite a few times here at least
in the set okay she's getting a lot of
mileage on the okie here all the grab a
nice jump up instant call out for the
same how dare you and the amount of
damage he got especially for picking and
choosing a spot same just very very
calculated on his own risk reward ratio
[Music]
defender in play what's he gonna do with
it
oh he gotta be dead I've done
omnidirectional but just not enough to
get the job you I'm saying with the et
block quick stab in the back and I've
seen the driver's seat right now but
fantastic call out see what he does here
again keeping that pressure on Chris
Christie hey a good step here but able
to put the brakes on it because of the
power of like what give what we're
talking about that's okay I mean as well
has a little bit of every has a little
bit of everything he has the muscle
buster rich takes ticket true to those
uh resets they're trying to slide up
most of us are instead is gonna get a
partition oh wow wait a minute he would
have thought he was out of Rage and so
did I but unfortunately I be saying
works in special ways
nice that was beautiful I decided just
keeping him out the range sniping you
know I'm gonna shoot over the head if he
doesn't and I like that right there
rich SIG's reaching for the stars
overextending there unnecessarily still
at a bar he's gonna SWAT to deal with oh
yeah hey I think he can't see God I felt
like he got out blasted I'm agile same
seemed extremely comfortable he's trying
to relax as well he is sticking with a
cell phone and it's like kill that
wasn't totally bad he just got
outclassed which was like clear to see
and sane he was like ever the century is
just like these deep breaths it's it's
all right right back into it oh nice
step to lead out there 6bb gets the
spike here let's see what he does with
it on the side step there you go
switching plane - what the dansgame
right in his face watch
now what you gonna do has a huge life
lead here this opening round nice this
is Phil he's out he's out shots
wow what a comeback I like it
let's ping them you can't whip man don't
got it all especially on open you know
edges forget the ivy it's just a slow
count they're saying all of these guys
are extremely high level are gonna be
looking forthe sidestep opportunity in
general you know to avoid some of these
verticals that they're getting Bob with
and if you give them a free open wall
young you're asked before that goes at
that point there we go ivy with the sole
charge right now and a huge life lead as
well oh and that's gonna be death there
you know he didn't breathe all the way
to us as soon as he was active enough to
be grabbed by the symphony they're just
straight-up snacks
already listen to the music break it
back down I thought that talking to you
is the epilogue we got eight credits all
right nice roll with the ground to avoid
that ground of damage rich six right
back out I'm trying to fish out oh yeah
playing again picking them to the skies
here nice grab calamity we haven't
really seen them all okay okay nice go
to the reversal edge see what he does
here good block there place a fall okay
very weird situation there and rich
states doing great with the ability to
switch and the movement to keep Saints
close enough to the corner there's that
- up in the middle that animation that
was fired here I go very careful my gosh
you just flash it in front of a freak
attack
TI o glad to be it anyways and at the
same situation tonight my time again
last hit losing the round
UGI
like you know looking for either the
regio or the re both of those attacks
would have lost the brake attack but
instead sing just starting go for the
muscle Buster's
now the mix-up so what's he to do that
Frank don't touch me okay I told you
listen stop it he's in his head down he
is in his head let's see what he does
here what's the follow-up it's a quick
stab fires off the sole charge but not
without taking damage first anything can
do it gear from rich steaks keeping it
safe sidestep into block I love that
just proves I'm messing it up because
movement itself is a mix up donkey going
up red cage keeping the red gain
securing the round rich sticks actually
in control here also has eat it apart
this is great to see I mean I obviously
have to that one sided opening match
here which sticks is really starting to
fight back and take it to save and the
thing is it's as well you can't really
count about at all absolutely not but
you can't scoop up by the legs if we if
he isn't watching them in a snatch it's
a double stomp it's from full screen but
it's not to it put it up to its top that
we don't want to deal with it alright
back gasps shoeless oh you wanna guess
power is power baby this is scary here
let's see what's the situation old get
some the public oh my gosh the timing
day needs to be so precise on that and
the follow-up from same that Swift kicks
gave him an opportunity to stay on top
cause which it's definitely Duncan
whatever button he was getting to was
coming didn't follow up what ever the
galaxy brain playing st. just knowing
when to put that extra move in the pot
cooking it up fixing it we'll talk about
the situation so rich sticks whatever
character you fix he is stuck with that
character for the rest of this set this
yeah with three straight matches against
Sain a tall order and he's gonna go back
to max less and then at any given point
no matter who you are
what game you play with you went down
and you've been playing somebody else
you will always always always always go
back to your pain what you know best is
like if the boat is going down
pick your [ __ ] exact you got to go with
your gut straight up alright anyways
we're gonna go right into this matchup
right now st. saving comfortably here
has a two-game lead rich six is really
gonna have to turn it up let's see what
he does oh nice hop over okay wrist
extort deep in the back seat he wouldn't
have done that with as well you know
even though it's just something so small
those little bits of obviously the
confidence of this character is me talk
to me it's also sweet I just looked away
for a minute $0.00 but faded I think
he's had a dunk false yeah I think Satan
wants to just get it to Grand Finals to
get it over with my party wolf you all
be something wrong if you OB he wants to
ran back he wants it oh okay wait a
minute he's in big trouble here with
this bad corner positioning a lot of my
visa moves in this there's no disrespect
hello and Saints don't play is looking
for it the whole time trying to get this
reverse ring to the other and rich takes
not taking the bait excellent on his
part as well yeah that was rough that
was sick there was so much they went
from the corner down survives a sole
charge don't setting it beats what now
sometimes you just gotta study your prey
just five seconds and wait for that
opening has the life lead in this
situation 10 seconds insane does not
have bar but instead backs he runs in
and gives them an opportunity at the
light please oh my gosh it's st. as it
oh my god fish sticks gets the hit yeah
lead don't follow it up clutch situation
there could've backed off but instead
let me go in and get this tap while I
was on the ground it's my she can do
from here
all right prick attack on the
continuation gonna roll on the ground
try to string it in there nice gi here
goes to the normal grab again but broke
it into the legal in whatever it 6s goal
so many highlight tapes of that lethal
here in this tournament alone is
spinning and the whiff punish daring
gets it the cancel the follow-up here oh
not out of the ring though he was
fishing for it still in big-time trouble
here with his back to the wall both
sides by I'm about I finished the street
a Spartan King just about oh you might
as well give it to him a single kick it
to the ring out could this be the start
of an amazing series of comebacks we can
we can we not I I just don't know what's
gonna happen here it's the trouble of
taking your main man maybe Maxie was
what it took all along and here's the
star to follow up knocking him down okay
get some counter and follow up here and
we'll see what he does a whole Christmas
tree gets the launch permit to follow up
good damage check the bait my swords
gonna play with him stand up I want to
talk to you for you slow down Maxie all
right follow up nice recognition oh my
gosh it stayed the omnidirectional event
is to go to move in the close quarters
situation at low health auto gi's hits
everywhere same oh and wait the second
one didn't compete didn't connect with
the recognition he knew his facing he
didn't have the topspin unlocked but
look at that able to get some good
damage here and again right now this is
set point for same same wins this round
he is moving to Grand Finals he wants it
oh oh
pushing him to a favorable position
let's see what he does here poppy
Oh Eddie's gonna get the whip bunnies
back just popped right on the head they
Bader look like a child in that
situation oh you want to play with you a
little we don't play net little uh
little skip it just give pop yeah he hit
him with a poppy - oh my god big
comeback talk to me a lot of damage
okay okay it's gonna go either way
final round both of you devil the sliver
of life levels gonna happen in the low
and the swift kick you're rich six
finally on the for two games to one
there is life yeah there is life but you
know what's about to happen
right you know the classic we're gonna
go all the way full conversion go baby
starting so fast that we could even
catch up to it here we go I like that
playing games running the tournament so
fast we have to speed it up ourselves on
the clock nice gets the counter hit the
follow up here into the back fist
I want that bread and I want that but
that for lunch you dinner
maxie players I should say you should
take us Lee lookout for that counter to
go ahead and get that follow up
something you absolutely need in your
arsenal
Oh laughing now it's funny it's not
funny when you're bright the edge of the
ring you gotta be careful
oh my gosh saying is it panicking at all
we've seen this but this time reach six
not going with respect there will be no
blocky except an excellent defense of
offensive balling I mean the thing is
there he use those mid kicks in such
great succession they're really trying
to snuff out any possibility where he
could get hit by one of those attacks
that pushes the my gun counter this is
Hertz such a tight match up between
these two get second hit and there's the
sweep starting to come out
follow up here what's gonna do oh look
wait a minute wait wait a minute is it
time going for the reset instead it's
looking for that water counter hit maybe
it's a relaunch watch to talk and I like
the idea but you can't put the star top
of the tree though not yet
two sodas oh he wants to grab again you
have to be very careful how we deals
with the ladies towards the corner it is
we don't need to see the curveball of
the animation rich Stig's knocking on
the door you feel me knocking well let
me in as he gets the battle for here
still has another par Peter so the same
wants to play the oh up just fine near
the edge game for six it's all about oh
the grab again this I'm getting a text
Joey played it'll be rich Nick showing
the power in this situation outside of
Christmas tree is one all of the up
tools battles intercity rounds just
getting outside of the range here this
is big though time's a-wastin their
weights out the soul shards now ready to
play the game once again she goes where
it gets the follow-up here again with
another good speed to follow a big meaty
damage in that situation working our way
towards the corner once again and yeah
it's name trying to jockey for position
but as this mystics right now all over
him looking for the with punish into the
sea II no soul charge you stay right
here and you talk to me let's have a
conversation saying things I want to
talk to you he have to finish the secret
saw so much momentum and rich sticks
pointing it down there's the first bit
of a push me see jumping out of his
chair of final game 5 listen man it
wasn't gonna happen any other way what a
beautiful sequence when you go back and
watch this those last 10 seconds that is
how you activate soul charge and that is
how you take control back see what
surprise why did you do this test you
just mentioned this might happen we're
now going to a final key I'm a realist
man I just call it like I see where he's
standing up was just ahead we're just a
little bit his swag level was on 98
99 because you know this one thought was
off to the side so see look good feel
good and look at that that look like
they stop nobody all that smiling and
laughing I'm telling you varmint the
smile was a defense mechanism
this is heartbreak I know psychology oh
and we're off this stage to uh let's go
Andy Maxie kidding the job done two
kings of piece put in favor and back see
it's too old if you want to look at it
in that light Saints falling apart at
the seams both men whipping lethal hit
opportunities in that situation spacing
here go ahead oh no oh no he might be
done just enough anything here I feel
like you know which six is done such a
great job out zoning it out Pacey well
how about papaya lethal hit shots to the
sky ring out is unnecessary that was
enough for the ko
this shooting oh here we go save finally
getting around that he needed that
Minnewaska she's got around lights up
there's the pack throw a lot of
sandwiches coming all in sequence
however rich six days behind mixing up
looking for the auto TI's instead it's
gonna block successfully stay out of
trouble point gets launched on the
second hit the sweep stick coming out at
st. trying to send a message working on
a perfect until that trade oh that's
gonna hit the follow up here and he gets
it and same again one round away from
moving on into our grandfather's okay to
bridge sticks expend everything he had
left into taking that last game just to
tie it I should have never stood up out
of his chair I don't know maybe have to
find a way here's some balance with
leaking fuel it ain't over till it's
over still has two parts of theater and
a lot of wall carry if he gave a
sequence for luck saying yo it was a
headphone adjustment it had to go other
way sidestepping trying to stay in terms
of dominate territory in terms of where
guys as well sit down talk to me get a
little bit of extension all the wake up
with fantastic all it is breaking them
to that's the thing
GI this time wrist six not having it if
you've got to go out that's not gonna be
the way
keep that pressure on but again he
doesn't have that much life left oh that
is dummy suffering just outside of the
range st. closes the door he takes off
his headphones just to have a quick look
with rich tick but I'm gonna win this
did you read that did you hear that go
don't win this that is all list that's
enough as a guaranteed victory for me
barking I'm gonna win this Wow
after the man who you played excuse me
the man beats you we'll put you in
losers you said they're gonna win this
that means you're gonna reset them and
win insane set from both of these
players of course man that was crazy
rich stakes got to give it up the third
place here at Thousand you fantastic
showing but unfortunately it's it's it's
it's rough I'll see Cuban I will give
you the flowers while you can still
smell them like as I have continuously
but not today it's just first only
because there's a show after this show
and I'm just caught up Saint said I'm
going to win this